論理ですか直感ですかというテーマでございまして
大変暑いところで
論理のところじゃないと思いますけど
私の頭もその状態になって
なんか焼いてる状態で
皆様もなかなかその論理的なことを
考えるところじゃないかもしれませんだけど
とにかくですから
できるだけ簡単に いくらか仏教的な話をさせていただきます
このテキストに書いてあるように
西洋的なこの脳の研究をする場合はね
右の方は感情的な芸術的なところとか
左の方は数学やらね
論理的なことをやってるんだというふうな話はあります
あまり脳の研究っていうのはね
それほどやってはないんですが
あの できないんですよ
でもそれなりにいろいろ
脳の機能に研究して
体の働きにも脳の中にちゃんと地図がありまして
その一部一部仕事を分けてもらって
手の動き 顔の動き 足の動き
そういうものを一部一部管理していると
言語はまたある一部で管理してやったりして
またいろんなものを記憶する部分があったりとか
そういうふうに部分に分けても
まだまだ脳のこと 脳のことはわからないですね
一番このわからないところは
人間は考えることなんですよ
だからコンピューターなどいろいろ機械作ったりするんだけど
そういうものには
新しく物事を考えることはできないんですね
人間の脳の不思議なところは
その考えるという機能なんですね
考えたり 判断したりする
だからそれも科学者は何か客観的な研究で
何か発見できないでしょうかというふうな
ところでは頑張っていると思いますけどね
なぜかというとものを考えるロボットでも
作ればいいんじゃないかなと
そうすると何でもプログラム組まなくてもいいんではないか
楽ではないかと　そこは映画の世界で
余計に考えてロボットに支配されている世界とか
人間を馬鹿にされちゃって
人間を奴隷にしてしまって
ロボットたちが世界支配するようになるんじゃないかなとか
そういうふうにSF的なね
物語までは作ってはいるんです
だから考えればこれ怖いんですよ
例えばロボットを一つ作ったところで
そのロボットに自分のことは自分でできるように
なってしまっちゃえば
そのロボットは次のロボットを作るでしょうに
それは自分の好きなように作ったりするんだから
もう人間には何もできなくなっちゃうんですね
それは可能性あり得るかないかっていうことはわかりませんけど
今までやっぱりできなかった
できないところは この考える機能なんですね
機械でできないことは
数学的な答えを出すのは機械的だから
コンピューターの方がはるかに早くやってくれるんです
でも それについて何か考えようとしちゃうと
それはコンピューターにはできないんですね
脳の働きっていうのはそれぐらいのことで
お釈迦様の教えとこれとどんな関係ありますかと
我々はこちらでお釈迦様の直接的な教えを紹介する場だから
あんまり西洋的な思想は言っちゃうとちょっと外れてしまうんです
お釈迦様の仏教という教えと
この論理と何か関係ありますかと
お釈迦様の教えは皆様ももう結構
お読みになっていらっしゃるでしょうし
原始経典に翻訳ございますし
だいたい仏教に興味ない方々でも
初めて読んでも ああ なんとかわかるんだと
理解できるんだと
初期経典だったら 後の経典が
例えば大乗経典なんかは
そんな簡単に理解できる論理的なものではありません
例えば般若心経がございまして
色は空であると 空は色であると
という何なのかとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
それもよくわかったようなふりをしている方々いるんだけど
それはもう大乗経典で
でもお釈迦様がおっしゃっているものは
中村元先生なんかね
日本訳されているし 増谷文雄先生とかね
最近片山一良先生も訳しているし
そういう真理の言葉とかね
神々との対話とかね
悪魔との対話とか そういう小さな小さなね
文庫本で出ているでしょうに
そういうものをお読みになると
あれこれさっぱりわからない
ということはないと思います
大体読んだらわかるんですよ
理解できるんですね お釈迦様の直接的な教えっていうのは
まあどんな例を出せばいいかな
大体どんな経典でも お釈迦様の教えだったら
読んだら人間にはわかるんですね
理解できるんですね でもそれと般若心経を比べてみると
何なのかとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
色は空であると 色って何なのかと説明していない
空ってどういうものかと説明していない
それで空は色であると書いてあるでしょうに
空すなわち色であると
空即是色と　そうするとみんな
当たり前ではないかと思っちゃうんですね
色イコール空であるならば
空イコール色ですよと
でも私はそれで人間の頭を騙されていると
本当のことを言っていないと
私はすごくいい加減なことを言ってますけどね
私の出す例は人間みんな死すべきものですよと
故に死すべきものはみんな人間ですよと
と言えますかと で それは間違うでしょうに
ですから色は空であるというのはいいんですが
空は色であると言っちゃうと
屁理屈じゃないかと
それはもう正真正銘の間違いなんですよ
だから論理的に間違いあるんだけど
もうありがたい教えだから
もうみんなありがたがって写経したりするんですけど
ありがたくはないんですけど
私にとっては で それと
この初期時代のお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
もうどこから見てもわかりやすいんですよ
そのわかりやすいってどういうことかというと
論理的なんですね 論理的だからわかるんですよ
この間 掲載 ニュース出たものなんですけど
ゼロ金利対策でを決めて
なんとか景気回復するだろうということで
そういうことに決めてあったんでしょうし
そこでいくら時間経っても一向にゼロ金利対策
景気回復はしません それでまたその偉い方々を集めて
ですからこの対策は続けましょうと
決めたんだそうです
だから そういうふうな心理は
論理はちょっとわからないんですね
なんでそうするんですかと
あまり効き目がないんだったら
そのままやめた方がいいんじゃないかなと一般的には思いますけど
だから論理的だったらわかりやすい
論理的でないとわかりにくい
ということがあるんです
それでこのお釈迦様の教えを調べてみて
本当にお釈迦様の教えかないかと知りたければ
論理性があるかないかと見るだけでも十分ですよ
一般的に読んで ああ そうでしょうねとか
ああ なるほどなと思えるような教えだったら
問題ないと思います
なんだこれという感じになるならば
これちょっと違うんじゃないかなとか
そういうふうになるんだったら
ちょっと考え直した方がいいかもしれませんしね
ですから人間には物事を理解するためには
論理性が必要なんです
それはもう避けられないんです
論理性がなくなっちゃうと
何も理解できなくなるんですね
できなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことで 大体我々は物事を理解するときは
覚えておくときでも なんとかの論理構成にして覚えてしまう
いろんな勉強するときでもね
こういうことは覚えておかなくちゃいけないと思ったら
何か頭の中で何か論理構成を作って
それで覚えてしまう ですから
人間の脳細胞っていうのは
やっぱり論理的なものを理解できるように
できているんですよ
ですから大体数学みたいなものっていうのは
結構人間にわかりやすい
歴史の勉強するよりも
考古学を勉強するよりも
数学の方がわかりやすいと思いますけどね
でも残念なことに数学嫌いな人々もいるんですが
それは別にどこかで自信がなくなったとか
あるいは先生の教え方が間違ったとか
そういうことではないかなと思いますけど
そうでないとあまりにも単純で
わかりやすいものだと思いますね
ですから まず人間に 我々には論理的
人間っていうのは論理的な動物であることは
一つ理解しておかないと
それで その論理って何なのか
ということがまた問題になってきて
論理的なんですけど
世の中で 我々はしっかりした
論理は持ってないんですね
論理自体はガタガタになってしまう
そういうこともありまして
あんまり明確にそれは理解しようとしないんですね
だから論理的に真理に至ることはあまりなくなってしまっちゃって
真理でなくなる場合もあります
だから 論理と真理という 2つをつなげて考えないと
論理的に物事を理解して
やっぱり最後には真理を理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
事実を理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことだから 仏教の世界でだいたいかなり昔も
論理学という学問を作ったんですよ
だから 自分の国の仏教学部の場合でも
仏教学部を卒業したければ
仏教倫理学という科目も一つあります
それもちゃんと一年授業を
受けなくちゃいけないんです
英訳もあって 日本訳もあるかな
ソ連の仏教学者で 昔のね
シュヴァツキという人がブディストロジックという
すごい大きな本 2冊書いてるんですよ
その本 2冊っていうのは昔あった
サンスクリット語で書いた仏教の倫理学の翻訳なんです
すごい明確に分析して
論理っていうのはどういうものか
ということをもうすごい厚い本なんですけど
2冊になってます
まだまだ本はいくつかありますけど
昔書かれた本はね ですから
この論理ということが
一応仏教に対しては大変大事なことなんです
大変大事なことなんです
なぜ大事ですかというと
仏教も一つ 世の中にあるたくさん
宗教の中で一つの宗教なんですね
一般的に見れば 一つの宗教だからといって
仏教もみんな言ってることは
ただ言葉を変えて言ってるわけじゃないんです
例えば神様の名前を変えるとかね
イエホワにするか アブラマズダにするか
ブラフマにするかとかね
各宗教で神様の名前は違うんです
ですから それで名前
誰が名前をつけたんですかとも聞きたくなっちゃうし
名前どうであろうが 神様ですからね
そういう風に何か仏教も
ただ世の中にあるごく普通の宗教で言ってる
同じことを言葉を変えて言ってるんでしょうかと
そこら辺は仏教はちょっと違うところがございまして
まず仏教の特色っていうのは
信仰というもの
信仰からすべて始まりますよという教えではないんですね
まず信じましょうと　それからあなたに
言ってることはわかるんですよと
そういう知識の土台は信仰ではありません
そこに仏教 特にお釈迦様はもうかなり
それ壊しちゃうんですね
信仰はダメだったら何がいいんですかと言えば
やっぱり出てくるのは論理なんです
インドのね今もある インドの宗教でいえばね
信仰っていうのはありますけど
インドではbhaktiと言うんですが
英語で言えば
faith beliefという言葉 2つありますけど
beliefという言葉がありますね
インドでよく使っている言葉っていうのはbhakti
インドで使うこのbhaktiという言葉
日本の適切な言葉はあるんだけど
私は今思い出せません
何ですか？日本語で言えばbhaktiは
ん？信奉 信奉じゃない
漢字はどういう漢字？
そういう信じると奉仕
奉仕 信奉と言いたいんですけど
一応 あの 何といいますかね
とにかく無条件で信じる
もうすごくやっぱり恐怖感みたいなものは入ってるんですね
信じるものに対して恐怖とも言わないんだけど
徹底的に頭下げて
信じるという意味でbhaktiなんですけど
英語の faith belief の場合は
このbhaktiほど怖さがないんだけど
すごくもうありがたく信頼して信じるというふうな
信頼して信じるっていうような意味なんですね
英語での言葉の場合は
bhaktiの場合はこの信頼するところじゃないんです
まあどうにもならないんですよ
状態で すごい向こうの方が強いんです
いわゆるいたずらに信じると
それは普通に
宗教といえば必ず出てくる条件なんですね
宗教でいえば まず信仰しなくちゃいけないんですね
いわゆる宗教の世界で
まずなんとかなんとかまず言ってくれる
人間に対して 人間はこういうものであると
こういう風にできたものであると
まずいくらかの説明はする
それはもう信じてもらわなきゃ困ると
信じたところで次の説明はわかるんだと
いや あまり例をいろいろ出しちゃうと
ちょっときつい言葉になるんだから
例えば人類が神様が作ったとする
まずそれを教えてくれる
あなた方は神様が作りましたよと
それまず信じなさい その項目を
はい わかりました 信じますと言ったところで
ですからこうしなさい
ああしなさいと それでそれからは論理は成り立つんです
だから人間は神様の命令を聞くべきですよと言えばわかるんですよ
なぜならば 神様が私を作ったんだから
私が神様が言うことをするのは当たり前ではないか
ということに論理が成り立つんですね
だから
そこは仏教の人はすごくややこしいところなんですね
だから壊しちゃうんですよ
なぜかというと 初め何か
何か考え方 知識をいくつかあって
それは無条件で信じる
信じてから次のこと論理的に成り立つと
わかりやすいですから
皆さんもよく勉強なさってるんだから
キリスト教の例を出しますけど
例えばキリスト教だったら
信仰するべき項目はいくつか決まってるんでしょうし
神様のことやら イエス様のことやら
受難を受けたことやら
それから復活したことやらね
それいくつかの項目ありまして
それはもう信じるしか道がないんですね
それを信じてからの説法はわかりやすいんです
人間お互いに優しくしなくちゃいけないんですと言ったら
はい わかりましたと
なぜですかと聞いたら
もうそれは聞いてはいけません
あれはもうとにかく信じなくてはならないんだから
私は勉強してた時は 私は聞きたい質問がありまして
キリスト教の学者の方々に
なぜ神様が人間を作ったんですか？と
で それに全然答えが出てこないんですね
だから私に逆に質問されてあったんですね
あなたはここまで聖書を勉強して
で でもここまでいろいろ合格もしていて
なぜ神様は信じないんですかと
だから私は逆に質問したのは
なぜ神様が人間を作ったんですか？と
だからそれは人間聞く質問じゃないんだと
そのわけは神のみ知ってるんだと
神しか知りませんと
ですからやっぱりまず信仰してしまえば
だいたい私も知ってますけど
信仰する人は聞く質問じゃないんです
聞いてはいけません 失礼ですよ
例えばキリスト教を信仰しながら
キリスト教の信者さんでありながら
なんで神様が人間を作ったんですか？なんでこんなことするんですか？と聞いたら
それはすごい神を侮辱することになっちゃうんです
そんなことは神様のことだから
神様のこといちいち聞くなよと
あなたはもう作られたものだから
言われたとおりに謙虚で生きていれば救われるんだよという
それぐらいで終わっちゃうんですね
だから私たちみたいに
外の人がそういう失礼な質問をすぐ聞いたりするんです
しても そちらは専門家なのに答えられないんですよ
向こうも別にそんなことを考えようともしませんから
あまりにも神様を非難することになりますから
だからとにかくなんでそういうややこしい状態が起こりますかというと
まず何かを証拠なしに信じるんですよ
だからそれは人間の智慧の世界で問題だとお釈迦様もおっしゃってるんですね
例えば このドアの外にキリンさんがいると
私は言います キリンさんがいますよと
信じなさいよと それで皆様方
はい 信じますよと で 言ったところでいくらでも喋れますね
キリンさんはどれほど大きいですか？どんな色のキリンさんですか？
あるいは置物として使えるものですか？何なのかとかね
それからキリンさんについて喋ると
やっぱりそういうキリン
ドアの外にキリンさん
キリンがいる さんと言うかどうか分かりませんだけど
あの キリンという動物がいますよ
信じなさいと言ったところで
仏教の立場はそうですか
調べましょうと 調べましょうと
調べていたならば それは餌をあげるべきかないかとか
それは後の話なんですよ
キリンは葉っぱ食べてるんだから
あんた方葉っぱ集めてくださいと言ったらいるかないかもしれないで
一生懸命葉っぱ集めたりする
それは仏教の見方はそういう見方じゃなくて
本当かないかと まず調べる
ですから この信仰という題をなしに
初めから論理的で始まっちゃうんですね
だから仏教は初めから終わりまで論理的に行くんです
それで面白いエピソードがあります
これ エピソードと言っても
これは経典なんですが
中部経典という経典がございまして
そちらで 何番目かとは
ちょっと思い出せませんだけど
象の足跡という名前の経典なんですね
象の足跡 それで経典 2つあります
大と小
小という名前をつけている
経典なんです その経典は大変
面白い経典で
ジャーナソーニというものすごい
金持ちのバラモン人がいたんです
すごいもう大金持ちで
バラモン人だから宗教家でしょうね
ですから いろいろ宗教なことをやって
結構金儲けしていたでしょうと思いますけど
祈祷やらいろんなことをやって
とにかくすごい豊かな有名な人で
彼がかなり贅沢しているんですよ
出かける場合は 特別に彼の特色っていうのは
かなり色にこだわって
よくカラーコーディネートするんですよ
だいたい白い色が好きで
白い馬 2つつけてる白い馬車
それで馬車の中のインテリアも全部白い色で
すべてインテリアまで作って
それから馬にハーネスとかいろいろつけますね
体に出す なんて言いますか
そういう馬の体につけている
つかめる
手綱とかね それは全部白い色で統一しているんです
それは自分も白い服を着て
白いターバンを巻いて
出かけるときは出かけると
そうするとかなり贅沢で豪華で
もう派手に見えるんですよ
そこら辺にあるものは何でもいいんだから
どんな馬でもいいんですよということは
その人にとってはそれはできません
その人は昼 出かけた時は
彼のよく知ってる行者がいたんですよ
有名な行者が 行者だから
あの彼とは全く正反対で苦行しているんですよ
で 名前はピローティカという名前なんですけど
まあそこに捨てたなんか布切れ一つ腰に巻いて
ただそれだけで 修行して歩き回ってるんです
だから性格的にはすごい正反対で
でもこの二人がすごいお互いの知り合いなんです
この贅沢のバラモン人が出かけた時
自分と全く正反対の生き方をしているこの行者に出会ったんです
出会ったら行者に君どこへ行って帰ってるんですかと
どこへ行ってきたんですか？と聞いたら
私は釈尊に挨拶しててもう帰ってる時ですよと
だからこの行者たちだから
あまり宗教にこだわらなかったんです
それはインド文化のすごく今はないんだけど
昔だとすごくいいところなんですよ
すごい柔軟性がありまして
で どこでも行くんです
だからピローティカ行者が別に仏教の信者さんではなくて
別な宗教の信仰していたんだけど
他の行者たちも他の宗教家たちにも挨拶したり
会ったり話したりする
自由に で 私はお釈迦様に会って挨拶して
帰っている時ですよと言ったら
君どう思いますかね？この釈尊という人は
これはすごい人ですかね
そんなにも とこの行者に聞くんですね
聞いたら行者がすごく怖くなっちゃって
あなたは何を聞くんですかと
私のようなものに お釈迦様はすごい人ですか？とかね
そんな判断できる状態じゃないんだと
自分が 自分にとってはもうあまりにももう上の人で
尊い人で もうそんな判断できるわけじゃないんだと
言ったら あんたよくも
で なんでそう言うんですか？と言ったら
この国でみんなに褒められてる人々が
釈尊のことを褒めているんだと
みんなに尊敬されている人々が
ですから 私にそんなことを
聞いてもとんでもない失礼だと
言ったら このバラモン人があんたは余計に
釈尊のことを褒めるのではないかと
何か訳でもありますかと
そんなにも褒めるために
別に信じてもないんですよ
仏教徒でもないんです
それは訳でもありますかと聞いたら
一つはあるんだと
私は釈尊に会ういろんな人々のことを見ていたんだと
インテリ中のインテリのバラモン人たちが
お釈迦様と論争をしようと
いろんなもう考え方を作って
質問を作って じゃあ今度は論争してやるぞと行くんだと
行って挨拶してお釈迦様と話を交わして
何の質問もしないで礼をして帰るんだと
お釈迦様の話に納得して論争しようとも
思い出すこともしないんだと
それをバラモン人のそれでシャトリア族
いわゆる王家の人々 それまですごいインテリの人々がいるんだから
そのインテリの人々も
釈尊の言うことは論争して破ってやるぞと
自慢して行くのは行くんだけど
行ってから普通の挨拶終わるところで
もう釈尊の話を信じて帰っちゃうんだと
質問しようともしないんだと
それで他の在家の人々も
またカースト 4つありましたから
インドでね あのワイシェというカーストの人々も
シュードラというカーストの人々も
どんなどの 4種類の人々がどのように質問をして
論争しようとしてお釈迦様に会っても
結局挨拶ぐらいで終わってしまっちゃうんだと
挨拶でお釈迦様でちょっと普通の会話交わしたところで
お釈迦様の話を信じて帰っちゃうんだと
だからそれを見たら お釈迦様はすごいと決めなくちゃいけないんだと
それで彼がたとえ言うんですよ
もしでっかい牙もついているオスのゾウを
探している人が森に入ったとする
森に入ったら ものすごいバカでかい
ゾウの足跡を見つけるんだと
あまりにも大きな足跡見つけたらわかるでしょう
ものすごい大きなゾウが森の中にいるいること
だから私はその 4つの足跡を見て
お釈迦様はものすごい人だともう決めたんだと
それはたとえなんですね
だから私たちもそうでしょう
例えば森にね 日本の森ではないんだけど
例えばアフリカの森でも入ったところで大きな足跡を見たら
やっぱりこれはすごい大きな象ではないかとすぐ決めるでしょうに
クマの足跡でも見たら
ああ これ結構百五十キロぐらいの
クマではないかとか決めるでしょうに
足跡を見たら それで間違いなしと決めちゃうんです
そういうことで その人もそれで私は間違いなしと決めたんだと
このバラモン人に言うんですね
そう言われたら そのバラモン人
このジャーナソーニさんがその話を聞いて
ああ そうですか やっぱり素晴らしいですね
お釈迦様と言って そんな素晴らしい人に
礼をしなくちゃいけないと思って
その場で馬車から降りて
お釈迦様がいる方へ頭を下げて礼をするんですよ
礼をして せっかく自分に何か用事があって出かけたでしょうに
その用事ももうそれは取り消しにして
じゃあこのままお釈迦様に会ってみます
と言ってお釈迦様に会いました
会って なんで私は私のような
有名な人がお釈迦様に会った
会ったんですかというと
こういう出来事があった
私の友人のあるピローティカという行者が
私に４つの象の足跡のたとえで
お釈迦様は素晴らしい人と説明してくれたんだと
だから来たんだよと言ったら
お釈迦様の答えは ピローティカ君が
たとえ説明していないんだと
あれは間違いだと
だからピローティカという行者が
お釈迦様のことを間違って説明しているんだと
というのがお釈迦様の反応なんですね
ただ このバラモン人はどういうことですかと聞いたところで
もしこの探検する人が鋭い知恵のある人であるならば
足跡が大きいだけででっかい象だと決めませんと
なぜならば 象にもたくさん種類がいるんですよ
今はほとんど絶滅状態になってもういないんですが
いくつかの種類があるんですね
ワーマニカという象の種類があるんじゃないかと
ワーマニカっていうのは背がすごく短いんですよ
高くないんです それで足はすごく太い
足の周りがすごく大きい
もしかすると その足跡は背が低い
ワーマニカという種類の象かもしれません
それからメスかもしれません
オスではなく だから足跡を見ただけで
決めるんじゃないんだと
それで正しく真理を探す人だったら
足跡で決めないで さらに森の中に入ってみるんだと
さらに森の中に入ってみたら
結構高いところの枝なんか折ってる跡が見えるんだと
ものすごい高いところの木の枝なんか折っている
象は食べるんだから それでも証拠は 2つ揃ってるんですよ
すごい大きい足跡とすごい高いところの枝を切って食べていること
そうすると背が短いゾウさんでないことは確かなんですね
背がすごく高い でも賢者というか
知恵のある人はそれで決めませんと
その証拠を 2つ握っただけで
なぜかというと またウッチャカーラーリカ
という象の種類がありまして
足が太くて背がすごい
もう細くて高いんですよ
いわゆる足だけ長くて体そんな大きいわけでもないんです
それで牙はない 牙は出てこない種類
もしかするとその象かもしれません
ですから 証拠を 2つ握ってももうダメですよと
さらに調べなくちゃいけないんだと
さらに森の中に入ってみると
入ってみると 足跡も見える
上の枝切って取っているところも見える
それで牙で木の高いところを刺しているところも見える
もう証拠揃ってるでしょ
大きな足跡があります
かなり背が高いという証拠を取っている
牙もあることももうわかるでしょう
もう決めてもいいんでしょうかね
お釈迦様はダメですと
それぐらい証拠あってもダメです
なぜかというと ウッチャーカネルカ
という種類の象がいるんだと
それも雌象なんですよ
体は長くて あまり体格あるわけじゃなくて
足はもう足の周りは大きい
上は細い で 胴体はそんな
大きいわけでもないんですけど
細い牙があります で それも雌象なんですね
だから決めませんと それだけで
それだけ智慧のある人はさらに調べてみるんだと
調べてみたら 自分の目で見えるんだと
バカでかい大きな雄象がすごい立派な牙を持って
そこら辺に歩いたり座ったり寝たり
枝を取って食べたりしているのを自分の目で見るんだと
見たところで決めるんだと
私は今までたどってきたこのいろんな跡が
このゾウが作ったものでしょうと
そこまであのたとえ説明しないと
私のことを褒めたことにならないんだと
そこで仏教はどこまで物事を信じることは嫌うかと
そのたとえでわかるんです
自分で確かめなきゃ もうどうにもならないと
そこでお釈迦様はそのたとえを置き換えて
ずっと在家のバラモン人に説法するんですよ
まず 頭の良い人々が 頭鋭い人々が私のところに来るんだと
来ていろんな質問したり
反論したり 論争したり
私と話してみるんだと
話してみたところで 私が喋っていることは真理であると
ものすごく納得いくんだと
やっぱりこれはもうその通りで真理だよと納得いくんだと
でも納得いってもそれで物足りないんだと
それでその人はこういうふうに考えるんだと
やっぱりこれぐらい真理は正しいと私は納得しているんだから
これは自分で試さないと
自分で実験してみないと意味がないんだと思って出家するんだと
出家してお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
大変いろんな戒律システムがありまして
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている戒をきれいに守るようになるんだと
その戒を守るようになったら
心は穏やかになって 心の苦しみが消えちゃって
ものすごく幸せを感じるようになるんだと
でも それで止まってはいけませんと
それから彼があの瞑想を始めるんだと
瞑想を始めると 禅定がありますね
第１ ２ ３ ４まで そういう禅定なんか味わって
で この上ない喜悦感 幸福感
経験するんだと でもそれでも納得いってはいけません
それで彼が次に智慧を開発しようと努力するんだと
智慧を開発したところで自分の過去を見えてくるんだと
自分が過去生でどこで生まれて
どんなように生まれていたんですかと
それで限りなく もういろんな過去生を
自分体験できるようになるんだと
それでも終われないんだと
終わってはいけませんと
それでその人にまた天眼という能力がついてきて
それも智慧なんですね
いろんな生命がその業によって生まれて死ぬこと
死んでまた生まれ変わること
それはいろんな生命がね
生まれて死んで また生まれて
また死んでという この輪廻の構造を見えてくるんだと
それでも物足りないんだと
次にその人はさらに頑張って
自分の心にあるすべての煩悩をなくして
心をきれいに解脱するんだと
で 解脱するところで あ
なるほど お釈迦様がおっしゃっている解脱は
こういうものでしょうかと納得するんだと
だから仏教で納得っていうのは
そこまでかなりきついというか
厳しいというか 普通の世の中で
中途半端で信じるというところじゃないんです
誰かの写真見せて これを空中浮遊しているんですよと言ったら
ああ やっぱりみんなで信じましょうと
だって写真があるんだからって
そんなレベルじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様が希望している論理レベルと
現代我々の論理レベルっていうのは
テレビで言ったんだからとすぐ信じるでしょうに
写真があるんだからすぐ信じるでしょうに
そこで UFO の写真とかあるでしょ？
テレビですごい番組やるんですね
今はもう ８月になってくると
お化けの番組とかどんどん出るでしょうに
まあ証拠あることあること
それでこういう心霊写真が出ましたとかね
だけど私たちっていうのは
それぐらいのことで
はい 真実だ 本当のことだと信じるもんなんですよ
だから簡単に信じるんだから
逆にどうなるんですかね
簡単に騙されるんです
簡単に信じる人はものすごい
とっても簡単に騙されるんです
そこであの象の例えに戻りますけど
象がオスかメスかということは
目で見なきゃわからないでしょ
知る方法はないんです
まあ 現代科学的な方法があるんだと言ったとしても
それはもう実験 試験管持って森に入るわけじゃないんだからね
尿のサンプルを取ってみて
尿のサンプルを取ったって
これなかなか無理ですけどね
まあ妊娠しているメスだったらわかるんだけど
そうでない限りはそんな尿のサンプルを
取ってもわからないもんですよ
オスかメスかぐらいでも
ですから そこまで判断を
何といいますか サスペンドと言うんですけど
何て言いますか 疑うんじゃなくて
えっ？保留する 判断を保留して
さらにさらに証拠を探していけばいいんです
そこで判断するのはもうはっきりと
もうこれはこれと もう他の結論が
出せないんだというところなんですね
だからこのお釈迦様の話っていうのは
大体 そういう態度で話してたんですよ
自分の国はお釈迦様の仏教は外国で始めた場合は
一番最初にスリランカという国でしたから
スリランカに伝道のお坊様方が行って
初めて教えた経典はこの象の足跡の経典だそうです
我々の歴史書にそういうふうに書いているんです
昔書いている歴史書なんですけど
で スリランカという島に来て
王様やら人々を集めてもらって
仏教は紹介しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
仏教はなかったんだから
それでこの象の足跡という名前の経典を
Cūḷahatthipadopama Suttaと
パーリ語で言うんですけど
それの大経典ではなくて
小という経典で説法したんだと
やっぱり私は気持ちわかるんですよ
まるっきり仏教を知らない人々にとって
信じなさいよと責めるんではなくて
信じなくても結構ですよと
判断は保留してくださいと
とことんチャレンジしてみてくださいと
その方が安心だと私は思いますよ
やっぱり信じなきゃあかんかとかね
そんな困ったりしちゃうと精神的に悩みが生まれるんですよ
強迫観念とかね いろいろ出てくるんだから
そういうことで このお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
ずっとこの自由みたいな
このフリーというかね
束縛はない だから 一般的な宗教にある徹底的に信じなさいと
無条件で信じなさいというのは
仏教から見ればとんでもない脅しではないか
というふうに感じることもどうしようもないんですね
これは脅しでしょうと
だから私は個人的に そうやって宗教的な対立ができた場合は
何のことない あんた人を脅してどうするんですかと
それぐらいのこと脅されると思ってるんですかと
地獄に落ちるぞとかね
で 日本のね 若い人々をね
前はテレビでも見ていたんだけどね
もう阿鼻地獄ですか
なんとかに落ちるんだと
自分の開祖様に悪口言ったらとかね
それで脅したりする で
やっぱりあれはすごい原始的な思考なんですね
だから今の時代  21世紀だといっても
心は原始状態だから それすごい困ったもんですよ
だからこの現代の方々の問題っていうのは
建物は作っているし
機械はいっぱい持っているし
道具は持ってるんだけど
頭は原始状態で原始人と何の変わりもない
はい 信じますと 原始人もそうでしょうね
太陽が出てくるとあまりにも驚いちゃって
やっぱり神様ではないかと拝んだりする
で 太陽神様ですってのは
はい そうですよと ヒンドゥー教でもスーリヤデーヴァというような
南インドにありますけど
すごい大きな神社というか
お寺というかね 太陽を神様にして拝むと
だからこの何でも信じる
という性格は 心の原始的な状態で
やっぱり調べて調べて実験して
試していくのは一向に構わないと
仏教の立場なんですね
そんなに怖がる必要はないんだと
罰が当たると思う必要もないんだと
ただ真理知りたいと 本当のことを知りたいと
本当のことを知って何が悪いんですかと
という態度でとことん調べていくような能力が
人間にあってほしいなというのは
仏教的な立場なんですね
ですから お釈迦様の言葉で
お釈迦様はいつでも言うのは
智慧のある人々が出てこいと
それはなんとなくお釈迦様差別ではないかと
智慧がない人はどうしますか？と
なんでそういう言葉を言いますかというと
やっぱりそう言わざるを得ない状態になっているんだから
だから あ 怖いと あ 尊いと
こんなことを聖者を宗教家を疑っちゃったら罰が当たるんではないかと
ということがあっちゃうと困るんですね
それも昔からのね インド文化であった一つの特色で
聖者を侮辱しちゃうととんでもない罰が当たるんだと
聖者の機嫌が悪くなることでもしたら
とんでもないことになるんだという
ストーリーはいっぱいあります
で 日本訳もありますね
マハーバーラタとかね
そういうマハーバーラタの日本訳でもあります
ストーリーばっかりなんですよ
あまりにも面白くないストーリーで私は読みませんけど
読んでやったらご飯も食べられなくなるほどストーリーなんですけど
結構あるんですけど その中でものすごい散々出てくるんですよ
聖者に失礼なことをして
すごく罰が当たったとか
今のヒンドゥー教で信仰している
神様の名前はラーマなんですね
で ラーマっていうのは昔なんとかいった
誰かの人なんですが
で 今の宗教の物語もそうやって
このラーマという人が誰かの聖者に
ちょっと失礼なことをして
その聖者に怒られちゃって
それでもう追い出されて
自分の国から で そこで苦労した物語があって
それでまた自分の国に戻ったと
まあ それぐらいのストーリーなんですけど
そのだから今 ヒンドゥー教の一番メインな
大事な物語なんですけど
それもやっぱりそうやって聖者をからかっちゃったら
もうただで済まないんだという
話なんですね そういう風に脅し入れて
置いちゃうと 人間が自分の探検能力を失っちゃうんですね
自分で調べてみようということが
なくなっちゃうんですね
だから西洋の場合はなんで西洋の方が我々よりも
すぐ発展してしまったかというと
西洋でものすごい脅しの宗教があったのに
キリスト教という　殺しちゃうんですよ
脅すだけじゃなくて それなのにみんな
チャレンジして科学的な研究したんですね
だからとことんチャレンジして
いろんな研究したところで
いろんなものを発見していったんですね
いくらなんでも地球は丸いんだと
丸いと言ったら殺すぞと
でもしょうがないということで
やっぱり丸いことは丸いと
だからこの どちらにするかなということが
未だに解決できない問題なんですけど
やっぱりそのポイントだけ
人間は真理を探すべきです
真理は何なのかと とことんチャレンジして調べるべきなんですよ
だからお釈迦様は自分のことを菩薩の時代で
自分のことをこう言うんですよ
kim sacca gavesī
これ自分のことをこう言うんです
これ悟る前 菩薩の時代で
自分がkim sacca gavesīでしたと
kimというのはwhat
saccaっていうのは真理
真理は何かと探検者 いわゆる探求する者
だから自分が真理は何なのかと
もう探求していったんだと
で それだけじゃなくてもう一つ
自分にお釈迦様 自分のことをこう言うんですよ
kim kusala gavesī
kusalaっていうのは善
善という意味で正しいもの
正しい生き方 真理は何なのか
正しいものは何なのかと
私は探求したんだと
そういうことでこの私 人間というのは
いくら時代経っても 人間の脳細胞にある能力は
やっぱり大事にしなくちゃいけないんですよ
やっぱりこの真理って何なのかと調べてみると
探してみると チャレンジしてみると
その機能は育てるべきなんですね
やっぱり人が言うことを何でも信じるんだったら
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですよ
信じやすい人は当然騙しやすい
それで逆に信じやすい人は悪いんだったら
何でも疑う人はどうですかね
何も信じません それもアホなんですよ
何でも疑う 何にも認めませんと
何も信じませんと これいとも簡単でしょう
どんなバカにもできますから
だから何でも信じるぞという人も
何も信じません 何も認めませんという人も
もう同じレベルなんですね
別にそれありがたいわけじゃないんです
だから私はそれぐらいにちょっと注意したいところなんですが
やっぱりそんな簡単に信じるなよということは
何でも疑って疑って疑いだけの人生いいわけじゃないんで
それも疑うのはいとも簡単
いい あんた言ってること信じませんと
ほか何か言ったら いえ
信じませんと 人がいくら証拠を
持ってきたのでも信じませんと
それはいとも簡単だから
信じませんと言うためにはかなり能力が必要ですよ
あなたのことを信じませんと言うためにも
こういうわけで こういうわけで
こういうことで こういうことで信じませんと
言わなくてはいけないんですよ
ですから 何が必要かというと
前に消した言葉なんですけど
論理性 論理性は必要になっちゃうんです
難しくなってしまいましたけど
これは頭がもう熱すぎて動かないんです
論理性って何でしょうかね
そこら辺 私はあまり喋ろうとは
計画を立ててないんですけど
難しいしね 難しいのは話じゃなくて
この例を出すのはすごい難しいんです
それにはいろいろ勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
大雑把で言えば 私たちは勉強している
知識 学校で勉強しているもの
科学とかね そういうものは大雑把で言えば
論理的なものなんですね
特に 科学系で我々が勉強するものは
大体論理的なんですね
だからそれはもう絶対的に論理とは私は言いたくないんです
科学は 私の嫌な言葉かもしれませんけど
現代科学はそこそこ論理的ではないかと
だからこのそこそこ論理性あるから
我々の役に立ってるんですよ
科学の発明やらね 発見やら
であの例えばこの科学と関係ない
考古学はありますね
考古学でお墓を掘ってみる
古いお墓 何かね ピラミッドでも何でもいいんですけど
古墳でも何でも で 古いお墓を掘ったところで
もう出てきた骨なんか見て
これは何年前のものですかと
考古学っていうのはそんな
科学的なものじゃないんだから
掘ればいいでしょうし
それだけのことなんですけど
やっぱり骨拾ったところで
これは何年前のものかというと
やっぱり科学は助けてくれないと
それで科学者がいろんな武器を持ってきて
いろんな機械を持ってきて
それにいろんな方法で
例えばこのカーボンというね
計算する方法がありまして
で そういう方法で一部をもう壊して
壊れてしまいますけど
それでこれぐらい古いだろうと
決めたりする で その年代を計算する場合は
そちらにはいくらかは論理性があるんです
例えばカーボンの放射性ですか
それはこれぐらいの割合で減っていくんだと
ということを知ってるんだから
今この物質のその放射性はどれぐらいかと見て
それから引き算で あ これぐらいの古いものだと決めちゃうんですね
でもそれもぴったし決めることはできないんですよ
まあ大雑把でこれぐらいではないかと
だから 例えば日本で発掘するものは
何でも日本最高なものだと放送するでしょ
どんなくだらんものを発掘したとしても
日本最高なものだと だからニュース全部並んでみたら
なんだバカなことを言ってるんじゃないかと
思っちゃいますかもしれませんけど
やっぱりなんであんなことを学者まで言うんですかというと
そこら辺は論理がないんですよ
かっこつかないんですよ
一番古い最高のものを発見できなかったら
それで余計に年代を入れちゃうんです
ある日本の同じ考古学者なんですけど
これやりすぎだと
非科学的だと そんな感動的な物語はありませんと
でも自分が言うことをだから誰も認めませんと
やっぱり 1万年古いものを見つけても
日本最高なものを見つかったんだと言わなくちゃいけないんだと
ということも話を聞いたことがありますけど
だからいくらか論理性があって
いくらか もういい加減な感情が入ったりする
で あの まあとにかく
まあそういうことは置いておいて
普通に我々が勉強しているものっていうのは
学校で大学で勉強しているものっていうのは
論理的な話なんですね
だから勉強しやすい　でも
なんで科学的なものっていうのは
じりじりと変わっちゃうんですかね
それは完全論理性は持ってないんですよ
何かデータを取ったところで
すぐ結論を出す 特にこの科学の世界で
特に科学といっても 宇宙のことを見る世界
ちょっと調べてみてください
ほんのわずかなデータでとことん推測して
推測して考えてストーリー作っちゃうんですよ
今コンピューターシミュレーション
というものができるんだから
こういう風に宇宙が現れて
こういう風に星が出てきてとかね
ものすごいインパクト強くストーリー作っちゃいます
あれはすべてインチキですね
で なぜかというと それは頭で考えた夢の世界で
撮った情報はほんのわずかで
だからこの この間 なんか日本で昔いたなんか動物の骨が見つかった
見つかったんだけど 小さな哺乳類の
ちょっと骨の一部しか見つかってないんですよ
それで全部他の骨格も決めちゃって
もう皮膚まで入れて もう全部動物も作っているんですね
だから一部だけデータはあるんだけど
そこからすべて推測で
補ってしまっちゃうんですね
だから皆様はもう恐竜の模型見てるでしょうね
ティラノサウルスやら
でも私は恐竜の皮膚は何色ですかと
知らんはずでしょうに
見たことはないんだから
骨は見たことがあるんだけど
だからそれにまた科学的な知識を入れて
科学的っていうのは論理的な知識を入れて
まあこれぐらい骨だったらこれぐらい筋肉でないと支えられませんとかね
で そうやって計算しながら体を作るんだけど
そこまではいいんですが
皮膚はどうしますかと
もしティラノサウルスの皮膚はカバの皮膚のように
ツルツルだったらどうしますか？
今はワニの皮膚のように作ってますけど
本当にその通りかわからないでしょ
それもどうか分かりませんけども
爬虫類というんですからね
しょうがないんですけど
ですからこの科学の世界でも
かなり芸術的な 感情的な夢の物語も入ってるんですよ
だからみんなに人気あるのは
この論理的なものじゃなくて
感情的な 芸術的な夢の物語なんですね
映画で恐竜を戦わせてみたりする
音も出したりする でも音は本当ですかね
あの音は 形まではいいかもしれませんけど
音の再現は全く不可能だと思います
科学的には　そういうふうなことで
我々 今おかげで助かっている
科学の世界にしても
厳密に論理的というよりも
大体大雑把で論理なんです
で それで仏教の立場は真理知りたければ
大雑把な論理でもいいんですけど
決めたもので止まるんじゃなくて
いつでも判断を とりあえずこうではないか
ということでいいんですよ
とりあえず やっぱり保留状態で
新しい情報が見つかり次第変えますよ
ということでいかなくちゃいけないんですね
だからその立場は宗教としても
使っているのはただ仏教だけなんですね
その科学的な立場 徹底的に調べてみる
だから怖いということはないんだと
だから仏教の場合は 宇宙は丸いか四角いか平らかというのは
それはお釈迦様には興味がない
なぜかというと 人間にとっては別に関係ないんです
宇宙は地球は丸くても四角くてもどうでもいいんだからね
人間にとって問題は自分の心の問題で
自分が幸せかないか 自分が苦しんでいるんでしょうか
あるいはすごい最高に楽しんでいるんですかという
そのところになってくると
人間ってのはえらいおかしいんですよ
人に言われると あなたは本当に素晴らしい幸せな人間ですよと
ああ そうですか 納得いくんですね
ある日本の宗教家の話を聞いてるんだけど
あなた方は光の子であると
神の分身である なんて素晴らしいかという
みんな納得するんです
そんな簡単に納得していいのかと
自分が幸せかなんか自分で知らないんですかね
それぐらい我々は自分のことになると
全く論理性失っちゃうんですよ
全くもう無知な人間になっちゃうんです
顕微鏡で何か見てちゃんと研究しなさいと言ったら
厳密に客観的に研究する
お医者さんはね 細い神経までつなげたりする
厳密にすごい難しいんですけど
血管も縫うでしょうに
切れた血管はまたつなげて
神経もつなげておいて
それで見えません 血液は流れてくるは　同じ色でしょうに
神経も血管もなんでもかんでも
見極めが難しい だから厳密に顕微鏡でつなげて
またテレビモニターでも見ながらよくやるんですよ
本当にものすごい 技というか
すごいもんなんですね
それなのに自分のことになると
完璧な無知な状態になる
だから仏教はそこら辺に研究課題にしているんです
自分を研究しなさいと
それも科学者が科学を研究するような感じで
地理学者は地面のことを研究するような感じで
生物学者は生物をどのように調べてみるかと
それぐらいの客観性で自分のことも
探検してみなさいと
だから仏教と科学の違うところは
この研究課題なんですね
で 科学の場合は自分のことを放っておいて
外の世界を研究する
だから いくら研究していっても
人間はそのままで だから21世紀になってるんだけど
我々の脳の働きは未だに
原始状態で脳は成長しない
物は発展する 洞窟で住んでいた我々は
今高層ビルで住んでいる
でも洞窟にいた人がそのままで
高層ビルの中の部屋の中にいるだけなんです
自分のこと何一つ分かってないんです
ですから この科学発展は人間の役に立ちません
お釈迦様の研究は人間の役には立ちます
その差がはっきりしているんです
だから私はこの仏教は科学的だ
科学的だというのは 科学だとは言わない
仏教も科学ですよということは言わないんです
科学的ですよというのは
やっぱり研究課題は違いますから
科学者は例えば地球の重さは測ったりするでしょ
いろんな計算して
これぐらい重いでしょうと
合ってるかもしれませんけど
だから我々にとってそれは
どんな役に立つんでしょうかと
自分の心の暗さを測ったことがありますかね
それは測ったことはないんですね
調べたこともない そういうことだから
自分で何なのかと厳密に客観的に
論理的に調べていきなさい
うん これはものすごい大きい課題ですから
そこら辺で淡々と次のポイントいくつか言って
もう終了したいと思いますけど
大体日本でも皆様も大体に同じ気持ちだと思いますけどね
あんまり 例えば日本の方々
あんまり西洋的に論理っていうのはちょっと
あまり好ましくないとね
あんまりにも激しく理屈ばっかしでとかね
という気持ちもあると思いますけど
本当は左脳の理屈ばっかしで何の味もないんですよ
だからって右脳の方の感情ばっかしで
それでいいんですかと
それはあまり意味がないんですよ
どちらでも真理には近寄らないんですね
理屈ばっかし働かせちゃうと
ただの空想になってしまっちゃうんですね
何も得られなくなっちゃう
それで感情だけで生きていると
何一つ分かったことにならないんですね
自分の好き嫌いで 自分の感情で
だからこれはものすごい失礼な分け方なんですけど
正しくないんです
この分け方は 私は分けたくないんだけど
西洋の方はものすごい論理的だと
理屈ばっかし 左脳寄りだと
やっぱり東洋は右の方寄りだと
思いがち場合もありますけど
それも決して合ってるわけではないんだけど
そういう現代我々の脳の働き
見るとどちらでも空想になっているんです
論理 理屈 例えば今医学の場合はね
体は論理的に分析して
機械扱いして いろいろなことをやっているでしょうに
それで本当に治療になるかならないかと
大体治療にならなくなってしまっちゃうんですね
論理だけだから 理屈だけだから
で 感情だけで言っちゃったら
また意味がなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの現代まで人間が感情を育てる
あるいは理屈を育てるという 2つやってくるんですが
仏教から見れば このどちらでも空想で終わっているんですね
そういうことに例を出すとすごく難しいし
私はそこまで例を調べてはないんですけど
理屈だけ考えちゃうと
どんな理屈もできます
例えば今Gなんとかというサミットがあるんですね
それでソ連はアメリカのミサイルディフェンスシステム
というものには反対すると
そういうリポートする人々が
どのようなリポートするかというと
ソ連というのはとんでもないことを
言っているんだというふうな感じで
ミサイルディフェンスシステム
というミサイルを作ることが正しいと
言いながら それに理由に持ってくるのは北朝鮮
北朝鮮がミサイルを作ったらどうするんですかと
だから論理的に考えているんですよ
北朝鮮がもしミサイルを作ったらどうしよう
あ 大変だ ですから 我々はものすごい
バカでかいスケールでミサイルを作ってやるぞと
あれはその人々が論理的やと思ってるんだけど
私から見ればもうあまりにも
無知な屁理屈に見えるんですね
だからソ連のプーチンさんが集まる前に
ささっと走って北朝鮮に行って
その人と話し合って だからいくらか論理的に
何かやろうとしてるんですよ
だからアメリカ側がどんな理屈持ってくるかというと
北朝鮮は良くないんだと
だから私は人類をすべて殺すために道具を
作るんだという理屈で持ってくるんだから
じゃあそれだったら北朝鮮の人からね
もうやめますと約束もらっちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
その人とさっとそちらに飛んで話し合って
そういう結論を持ってサミットに参加するんですね
なぜかというと やっぱりそんな危ないことを
やばいことをやめましょうという
考え方だと思いますけど
だからこのこれからの世界っていうのは
この武器開発ではもう生きていられないんですよ
もういい加減やめた方がいいんですよ
人殺すことは でもこの理屈型の人間が人殺すことは正しいと
平気で論理作っちゃうんで
あれは論理的じゃないんですよ
殺すのも論理的に正しいし
殺さないのも論理的に正しいというんだから
だから論理だけっていうのは何の役にも立たないんですよ
だからみんなも誰に頭にも浮かばないのは
この違う道があるんじゃないかと
平和を維持するためにどうすればいいんですかと
例えば 第三世界の国々の借金とかね
それはどうするんですかと
それは話そうともしないと
死ぬ連中は死んでもいいと
我々にも大きな問題があるんです
武器はどれぐらい作ればいいかという
そういうのはもうアホもいいところでしょうに
だからもう一つ思考があるはずなんですけど
それは頭に出てこない
あまりにも論理という論理というか
理屈ですね 理屈ばっかしで働いているんだから
事実見えなくなっちゃうんですね
だから例えば私は答えで言うんですけど
そうやって大きな人間
国々の人々がね もう集めて
地球はこれからどうなるでしょうかと
どうすればより豊かな世界になるんでしょうかと
無駄な費用をね どういうふうにすればなくすんでしょうかと
そういうふうには考えようとも微かにでも思わないんですね
それも理屈にしたとしても
結局もうそうやって屁理屈で終わってしまっちゃう
例えば日本も頭で妄想しちゃったら
北朝鮮がもしミサイル一つ撃っちゃったら
日本に向かってどうしましょうかと
まずそれを仮定する それからそれを信じる
信じたところでもう怖くてもういてもたっても
いられなくなっちゃうんでしょ？
ミサイルが飛んできたらどうしますか？
だったらもうあっちこっち
また北朝鮮に撃ち返すためにミサイルを
置いておかなくちゃいけないんだ
ディフェンスシステムを作らなくちゃいけない
それからとことん考えてディフェンスシステムを作ったりする
すべての資源を最後はそこに行ってしまう
それで何年待っていてもなかなか撃ってこないし
こちらも撃ち返すこともできなくなっちゃうし
そこで 10年経っちゃうと
もう 10年じゃなくて5、6
年経っちゃうと もうああいう機械は使えなくなる
で また新しく作り直さなくちゃいけない
そういうやり方はどこまでやるつもりですかね
日本が別にそんなことをやっているわけじゃないんだけど
どのように理屈が生まれて
発展するかっていうことのいい例なんですよ
日本はまだやってないんだから
まだ実感していないんですね
北朝鮮からミサイルが飛んでくること
あの軍事世界で産業をやっている人々は
本当にそうやって厳密にこの妄想っていうのは
実際に思ってるんですよ
ものすごい具体的に思って
それからもう狂暴になって政府をいじめてお金出せと
で 例えばこのミサイルディフェンスシステム
というものを作ったりしちゃうと
もしかするとアメリカが技術は素晴らしいんだから
スズメが飛んできちゃっても
すぐ 反応してミサイルがパッパッパッとね
花火のように出てくるようになる可能性もあります
アメリカの空のアメリカの領域の空に
スズメが飛んできたんだと
それはコンピューターがもうすぐ反応して
あまりにも敏感なシステムで
まあですから そういうふうに
非現実的に ただ理屈ばっかり働かせちゃうと
そういうふうに無駄な世界
今の世界 そういう世界なんですね
21世紀まで作った世界っていうのは
全て無駄 無駄だけの世界
理屈だけで働いて で 逆に感情だけだったら
映画やら美術だけ 絵画描くだけの世界になっちゃうんですね
例えばみんな芸術家になっちゃって
みんないろんな絵の具を持っていて
いろいろ絵画ばっかり描いていると
食い物はないと それも何の意味もないんですよ
音楽は楽しく聞こえるのは
お腹がいっぱい食べた時なんですよ
食べるものもない状態で
ものすごい立派な絵画をそこ描いたんだとかね
それ何の役にも立ちません
ですから 感情的な世界も人間の役には立ちませんし
我々の左脳ばっかし動かしている理屈の世界も
人間の役に立ってないんですよ
結局 もう破滅の方向へ持っていくだけ
だから世の中 全然脳細胞は発達しない
まず持ってる脳細胞も変に使っちゃって
もう破滅の方向へ持っていく
だから我々は違う道があるんだと
違う道があるんだとずっとおっしゃってはいるんです
仏教は論理否定しているわけじゃ
仏教は厳密に論理的 厳密に論理的だから
もう空想的な理屈ばっかりやっているから
それはないんですよ それはお釈迦様はすごく反対するんですよ
それの一つのエピソードがあるんです
それも経典から出てくるストーリーで
ある人が宗教の行者なんですけど
いろんな宗教を探検している間で
お釈迦様のところにも入ってしまっちゃったんです
あの道場巡りで 道場を巡る過程で
お釈迦様のところにも入って
そこで出家して瞑想を始めたんです
瞑想を始めたら この人はいくらか心が統一してしまって
あの異次元的な いわゆる天界の神々というかね
天界の住人たちを見えるようになってきたんです
瞑想して もうある一定のレベルに行ったら
見える いわゆる今風に言えば
何て言いますか 何か霊能力みたいなもの付いちゃって
そこであまりにも美しい
天界の神々のあまりにも美しい姿を見たりして
でも彼には音声はないんです
あのテレビの音声はミュートにしているような感じで
映像は見えるんだけど
音声はない 音は聞こえない
だから彼に実際に神々が
その時やっていることは見えるんです
ライブで生で見えてるんだけど
神々が喋ったり 踊ったり歌ったりするのは見えるんだけど
音は出てこないんですね
それでこの人はもうこれはお釈迦様から
直接指導を受けて瞑想するわけじゃないんだから
お釈迦様のところに行って
お釈迦様に報告したんですよ
自分が瞑想していると
神々がいろいろやっていることは見えるんだと
でも何喋っているか 何を歌っているかと聞こえないんだと
どうすれば自分には音声のチャネルもついてくるんですかと
聞いたらお釈迦様は全然何も言わなかったんです
何も言わなかったんです
それにすごく怒ったんです
この行者は これ嫉妬しているんだと
もし私に神々も見えて
神々の声も聞こえるようになったら
お釈迦様と同じ能力でしょ
嫉妬しているんだ だから教えてくれないんだ
いくらなんでも 後ででも教えてくれるだろうと
教えてくれなかったら
とにかくその方法ももう盗んでやってみるぞということで
一緒に出家して 一人の比丘として生活しているんですよ
生活して修行するんだけど
なかなかこの能力ついてこない
いろんなお坊さんたちに聞いてみるんだけど
でもうまくいかない それでもう諦めて怒って還俗するんですよ
還俗して もう言いたい放題悪口を言うんです
仏教について 一番お釈迦様が
気になった悪口があるんですね
お釈迦様はただ論理的に喋っているだけですよと
理屈で喋ってるんだと
だからお釈迦様はすごく反対する
ものすごく嫌がると言ってもいいかもしれません
お釈迦様を怒らせる言葉なんです
この言葉は
まだ長い文章ですけど　まだ長くありますけど
じゃあこれだけでいいです
takka pariyā hataṃ samano gotamo dhammaṃ deseti
takkaっていうのは論理ロジック
いわゆる論理的に組み立てて
論理的に徹底的に組み立てて
samano gotamoってのお釈迦様のことを
gotamoだからお釈迦様の名前は
まあこれ英語じゃないんだから
大文字書く必要ないんですけど
名前だからまあ大文字で書きましょう
Gotamo　samano Gotamoが
いわゆるお釈迦様が論理的に組み立てて組み立てて
dhammaṃ desetiと説法してるんですよ
だから破れないんだから
それは悔しい お釈迦様が喋るとものすごい説得力あったし
あれはただ論理的に組み立てて喋ってるだけですよと
そういうふうなことを言いふらしちゃったんですよ
この人が これ言われるとお釈迦様は結構ただでは済みません
もう大変な怖いんですよ
そんなこと言われたら
仏教の世界では で 彼がそんなことを言いふらしちゃって
論理的に喋ってるだけですよと
お釈迦様にはその経験はないんだと
その言ってることはいわゆる実行して経験してるわけじゃないんだと
いわゆる口うるさいだけですよとね
今の言葉で言えばね ただ口うるさいだけです
よくベラベラ喋るんだと
で こうやって言って でももう一つ
彼がお釈迦様を非難するために
もう一言葉
付け加えるんですよ
でも彼が言った通りにやってみるとなかなかうまくいくんだと
でも本人がただ理屈を組み立てて喋ってるだけですが
でもやってみると まあその通りにはいくんだと
言ってる通りに それどういうことかというと
自分もちょっとやってみたんだから
やってみた部分は嘘ではなかったんですね
その話を広げたところで
お釈迦様はすごい
それにはもう認めたくはないし
ものすごいいきなり立ち上がって対立しちゃったんです
お釈迦様にその報告が入ったところから
お釈迦様ははっきり言ったのは
あのアホが私を非難しようとして褒めているんだと
それぐらい頭が悪いんだと
人を馬鹿にするんだったらはっきり
馬鹿にしなさいよということなんです
私を非難しようと思って賞賛しているんだ
それも論理的に崩しちゃったんだ
お釈迦様 この非難の言葉自体
だって お釈迦様がいい加減
理屈ばっかり喋ってるんだけど
言ってることは実行すればその通りになるんだったら
それはお釈迦様の賞賛になるでしょう
だからお釈迦様は自慢できるでしょう
でしょ？嘘じゃないでしょうと
言ったことは　言ったことは
嘘じゃないでしょうと言えるでしょうに
だから人をけなそうとしたとしても
その方法さえもわかってないんだと
言ってお釈迦様はすごい
きつく攻撃したんですよ
ですごいきつくその人に攻撃して
経典でずっとストーリーはありますが
時間はなくなっちゃいますからね
そこら辺ちょっと省きますけど
どういうふうにも対立が起きちゃって
で 彼が他の聖者の他の宗教家のところに行ってね
その宗教の人が自分にはお釈迦様よりすごい超能力があるんだと
超能力自慢してるんですね
お釈迦様は全然超能力自慢はしない
超能力には反対だから
超越した能力は賛成するんだけど
超能力は反対です ですから
お釈迦様は論理的に喋ってみんなに悟りの道を教える
そういうことだから 他の宗教の人々は
超能力を売り物にしちゃうんですね
するんだけど 誰も証拠は出さない
ある行者が自分にはすごい超能力があるんだと
釈尊なんかはね 一つ超能力を見せちゃうと
私は 10個ぐらい見せてやるぞと
なんだ あんな釈迦っていうのは
まだまだ若いではないかという感じで
お釈迦様のことを批判していたんですね
そこでこの人はすごく気に入って
やっぱりさすがいい先生に出会ったと
お釈迦様を馬鹿にするためにはいい人だと言って
お互いに話し合って
話して話を広げてしまって
一般人にも知られてしまって
そこでお釈迦様にチャレンジかけてるんだと
超能力はお釈迦様にはできなくて
ある行者にできるんだと
言ったところでお釈迦様は
王様がその報告したんですね
言ったらお釈迦様 これはもうただで済まないんだという
お釈迦様はすごく怒ったでしょう
この言葉に 私はただ理屈ばっかり
喋ってるんだと言うんだったから
じゃあ私はじゃあチャレンジ受けますと
挑戦状 誰に超能力あるかと
やってみましょうと言ってお釈迦様は場所を決めた
そういう場所でこの日に来て集めてくださいと王様に言って
あんたみんなを集めてみなさいと
ただ 王様が逆に困ったんですよ
なぜかって お釈迦様はそれを禁止しているんですね
特別な能力は いかなる理由があっても
一般の人々に見せてはいけないと
お釈迦様は弟子たちにもみんなにも
やってはいけませんと禁止していることを
お釈迦様はやるぞと言ったら
王様が困って　王様とお釈迦様
すごい仲が良かったんですね
困ってお釈迦様のところに行ってお釈迦様
そういうふうに言っても困るんじゃないかと
これやっぱりないことにしましょうと
あの人が一人勝手にこの森の中で叫んだとしても
関係ないでしょ お釈迦様にとっては
そんなことを気にする必要はないんだと
お釈迦様はもしちょっとだけでも超能力なんか見せちゃったらね
これ困ると なんで困るんですか？と
だってお釈迦様はみんなにそれを禁止しているでしょうにと
だから法律を犯すことになるんだと
仏教の法律 それお釈迦様自身で法律を
犯しちゃったらもっと困りますよと言ったら
お釈迦様にもうお釈迦様も
もう何といいますか 下げません
もうお釈迦様は一番攻撃する言葉で批判されたんだから
お釈迦様は王様に じゃあ君に聞きますけど
君はいろいろ法律を作ってるでしょ
自分の国民に あんた守ってるんで
それは あんた破ったらどうしますか？といえ
私は法律を作ってるんだから
私にはその法律関係ないんだと
いわゆる王様が最高裁判官で
もう自分を調べる人がいない
自分が一般国民にこうやってはいけない
こうしてはいけない 泥棒してはいけないと言ってるだけで
だから法律は王に効かないでしょうと
聞きませんと 法律的にはと
だから私は法律を作る人やと
私は比丘たちにやってはいけないんだと言ってるんだけど
私もやってはいけないと言ってないんだと
だからやりますと で 王様に言うことも聞かないで
その場所で集めたんですが
あの行者は現れなかったんです
で お釈迦様はやっぱりまあそんなもんだと
私の前には来られないんだと
できれば運んででも連れてこいと
運んででも連れてくることはできなかったんです
その宗教家　そこでお釈迦様は特別な自分の能力を
みんなに見せてという話ですけど
まあとにかくそのストーリーは関係ないんだけど
そこでこの純粋に論理ばっかり喋ることは
仏教はどれほど嫌っていたかという例なんですよ
あのお釈迦様さえも腹が立つんです
理屈ばっかりではないかと言われると
理屈ばっかりじゃないんです
だから 単なる理屈ばっかりで
何の意味もない空想になる
単なる感情だけで事実から必ずずれてしまっちゃうんですね
例えば 私たちは勝手にあの人のことを嫌いですよと
気に入らないんだよと思ったら
それで終わっちゃう 嫌です
気に入らない 好きじゃない
そうすると その人がどんないいことをしても
どんな立派な人であろうとも
もう事実調べようとしないんですね
まあ嫌いだから嫌いですということで済みますね
そういうことで事実に至らなくなっちゃうんですね
理屈だけだったら同じことなんですね
だって決まったんだから
こういうことですよと
こういうことだから こういうことだから
そうやってもう残酷に理屈で決めつけたりする
例えば この患者さんががんですよと
がんだったらもう摘出するしかないんだと
いい ちょっと考えて 考えることはない
がんでしょ じゃあ手術して取って出す
取り出す それは決まりと
そうすると理屈ばっかりでしょうに
あるいは逆に その患者さんが女性で結構美人だとする
やっぱりすごい美人だから
やっぱりもったいないな
なんて言いますか メスを入れて傷跡それやっぱりダメですね
やっぱり可愛いんだからと
感情で やっぱりこんな可愛い美人なのにね
やめましょうよ もう傷跡ついちゃったらかっこ悪いんですよ
どちらが正しいんですかね
あなたの心臓にではなくて
肺にもう両肺にももうがんが入ってるんだ
じゃあ取りましょう がんが綺麗に
周りの筋肉全部丸ごと取った方が
がん細胞が消えちゃうんだと
という理屈が成り立つか
やっぱりこんな美人だからね
これちょっともったいない
だからメス 入れてはいけませんという感情の方
どちらにしたって答えが間違ってるでしょ
判断は間違っている ですから
論理型も良くないし 感情も良くない
いわゆる脳の左も使う
使う方法 我々の使い方は良くないし
右の方も使い方は良くないんですよ
どちらでも我々には結局苦しみしか作ってない
音楽家も芸術家も美術をやっている人々も
みんなもう地獄の苦しみを味わっているし
そこで科学的な研究ばっかりやっている人々も
ものすごい苦しんでいて
ろくな結果は人類にやってないんですよ
それで仏教的な立場というのはすごい違う立場なんですね
例えば人を殺してはいけないと言っているんですね
それは単なる命令じゃないんです
すごい論理的なんです
なぜかというと 厳密な論理で考えると
私は相手を殺す それ正しければ相手が私を殺す
それも正しいでしょ すごい厳密な論理で考えてください
私は人を殺す それは正しい
いいんですよ 決めたら
だったら相手が私を殺す
それは正しいでしょう
そうすると 誰が誰を殺してもいいんです
論理的に誰が誰を殺したとしても
別にどうってことない
それ純粋論理なんですね
そうすると そこでそこで止まらないで
もう感覚的に感情的にはどうですかと
まあ私が嫌だから こいつは嫌だから
やっぱり殺したいんだと
だから人を私が人を殺す
それは嫌だからいいんだと
決めるならば 人が私を殺すと
それはいいことだ いい？
自分が死にたくないと
自分が殺されてほしくないという感情があるでしょうに
そこで論理的にだけじゃなくて
感情的に計算してみると
私を殺されて 私を殺されてほしくない
ということがあるんですね
で それまた論理的に持っていくんですよ
私を殺されてほしくないということは
相手も相手を殺されてほしくないということでしょうに
だから殺されてほしくないのに殺すということは
相手の気持ちを無視したことになる
だから相手の気持ちを無視することは
相手のいわゆる権利 人権ですか
それを無視することにもなる
じゃあ自分の方に見てもらえば
自分の気持ちを無視することは一番嫌なんですね
私の気持ちを理解してくれ
私の気持ちもわかってくれという願いだから
それで理屈の論理的な部分と
人間の感覚的な部分を混ぜて考えちゃうと
結論は殺してはならないということになるんです
殺してはならないと それで次に
それは人間だけですかと
調べてみると どんな生命もやっぱり
自分の命を可愛いと思っている
だから自分の命を可愛いと思っているのに
その生命を殺すことは
その生命の人権を奪うこと
になるんですね だから殺すなかれというならば
いかなる生命も殺してはならんと
それではっきりした法律的な
文句が出来上がっちゃうんです
それはもう変えることはできません
誰にもできません この人間の中でいい加減自分の好き勝手に
だって殺さなきゃ生きていけませんと何か屁理屈言いますけど
正しく論理的にやるとこれは変えられません
例えば やっぱり人間が手紙なんか来る場合
読んでみると 人間は魚を食べているのではないかと
だから魚ぐらい殺してもいいんじゃないかという人もいる
理屈はどこにあるんですかね
ああいう屁理屈出てくるんですよ
普通の人間の中で だから私に質問がいくつか来たんだけど
やっぱり生きる上ではやっぱり魚ぐらいでも
食べているのではないかと
ですから 魚取ってる漁師たちが魚取ってるでしょう
だからその殺生はいいんじゃないんでしょうか
そこでどんな理屈ですかね
皆様にわかりますかね
私もあまりこの答えません
その時はちょっと避けますよ
なぜかというと すごいものすごい大胆な答えを出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからなぜ魚は殺すべきかと
その人を決めるのは私が食べるんだからなんですよ
私の餌ですよということは
殺す理屈になるんですかね
だったらライオンに私を殺す権利は十分あります
もし私が今日から人間の肉食べるようにする
そうすると私に人を殺す権利が成り立つでしょ
人間の体に一番いい人間の肉なんですよ
だって魚っていうのは泥ばっかし
食ってないものばっかり食べてるんだからね
肉も良くないし 鶏やらね
豚やらどんな汚いものばっかり食べて　食べてはいけませんよ
体に悪いんです すごい上等なものを食べている人間の肉は
ほとんど人間の体に必要な材料は全部揃ってるんだから
だから一番体にぴったし合う最高なものを食べたければ
人間の肉を食べるしか方法ないんです
それである人が じゃあ私は今日から
人間の肉食べると決めちゃったら
その人に人を殺す権利が成り立つでしょうに
だって私は人間の肉を食べてるんだから殺してるんだと
だってあなたは魚食べてるんだから魚殺してるでしょと
そういうのは屁理屈とわかりません
そうすると だから人間が魚食べてるんだから
魚ぐらい殺してもいいんじゃないんですか？
というのは何にも成り立たない論理なんです
だからこの論理も論理で
本当に仏教以外では論理できないと思いますけど
だから私も本当に遠慮して
あまり論理的には言ってないんです
論理的に言うと こんな本当にとんでもないんですよ
ものすごいガタガタと
この作っている世界っていうのは壊れていくんですよ
だから逆に皆様方は仏教を勉強して
もっと元気になって この弱いこの我々
失礼な言葉なんですけど
もういつでも腰抜け性格でしょ
まあもう腰低いというよりは腰抜けなんですけど
腰が引くのはいいんだけど
まああっちにペコペコ
こっちにペコペコ ああそうですか
そうですかとか そうじゃなくて
もう堂々と生きていられるんですよ
お釈迦様の教えを理解すれば
だから自分の生き方 自分の足場はしっかりするんです
だから自分の島は自分でしょうし
仏教ではね 本当にすごい厳密に論理だったら
厳密に論理使うんだけど
やっぱり人間作っている理屈とは違うんで
それでも人間の理屈はいつでもおかしいんだから
例えば平和はいいんですよと言いながら戦争を正当化する
戦争の場合は 例えばイラクとどこでしたっけ？えっと
クウェート で イラクはクウェートを侵略したでしょ
そこでアメリカが入って入り込んじゃって
もういっぱい爆弾を落としても負けちゃったんですね
そこで負けたんだから
全部お金払わなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそこで論理はどこですかと
例えば日本は戦争で負けたでしょうに
で 負けたんだだから日本は全部
お金を払わなくちゃいけないんですね
それで もし日本が勝ったならば
第2次世界戦争で 負けた人々は
みんなお金を払わなくちゃいけないと
あれ？あれは理屈ですかね
だからそちらの理屈は
勝った人の勝ち 勝った人は正しいという理屈でしょうに
屁理屈だとおわかりでしょう
戦争の論理は 戦争は
勝った人は正当派で 負けた人は間違ってるっていうことでしょうに
そこで戦争の手段から見れば
凶暴であれば凶暴のほど
残酷であれば残酷なほど勝ちやすいでしょうに
すべて道徳もなんだかんで無視して
原子爆弾でも何でもばらまいたりとかね
劣化ウランでも何でもいいんだからって言って撃ちまくっちゃうと
イラクでやったような感じで
爆弾を雨のように降って降らせてやるぞと
で やっちゃうと 凶暴であれば凶暴のほど勝つでしょうに
ですから 凶暴な人 残酷な人
殺戮の意識が強い人が正しいということになるでしょうに
そういう論理であって
もう負けた人は大量殺戮したことはとんでもないことだと
また裁判で裁くと 僕らから見ればもうむちゃくちゃなんですよ
この理屈じゃないんですよ
むちゃくちゃなんですよ
例えば 国同士で戦ったならば
両方間違ってるでしょうに
仏教から見れば なんで殺し合うんですかね
だから もし国二つ戦った戦争をしたならば
両方間違っちゃって 両方とも賠償金払わなくちゃいけないんですよ
勝っても負けても関係ないんだと
全部払えと 誰に払うんですかというと
それとんでもないことで
いろいろ政府やらみんな余計な盗んじゃうんですね
そのお金を それで戦争で誰が一番困ったかと
一般国民でしょうに いつでも平和で生きている人がやられるんですよ
誰にも悪いことをしないで
自分で自分の畑を耕して
子供にご飯を作ってあげて
普通に生活している人はみんな苦しんじゃうでしょうに
今もあちこち戦争あるでしょうに
それで難民になって あっち逃げるわ
こっち逃げるわ もう病気になるわ
途中で子供たちが死んでしまうわ
戦いたくない ただ平和で暮らしたいと
思う人々が一番悲しい思いするでしょうに
だから そういう人々に損害賠償を
両側から払わなくちゃあかんですが
論理的に考えちゃうとそういう世界じゃないでしょうに
だから世の中の理屈は私は全然認めません
まるっきり理屈はないんだと
論理はないんだと 屁理屈だと
だから論理あるのはお釈迦様の教えだけなんですよ
それはもうしょうがないんです
きつい言い方かもしれませんが
それはそんなこと言ってはいけないんですよ
我々は仏教だけ正しいとかなんとかとかはね
それを皆様が決めるんであって
これは探検して本当かないか調べることなんですけど
一応まあ自分の個人的な判断で言えば
それぐらい厳密に正しい論理性は
お釈迦様しか語ってないことは確かなんです
だから 例えば仏教の立場から言えば
なんで人が戦争をするか
なぜ戦うかと 一つは自分が正しいと
自分が正しいと誰が決めるんですかね
相手が間違っていると
そういう気持ちでしょ
それで戦争が起こるんですよ
それは一つのわけ それ自体屁理屈でしょ
自分が正しいかないかということは
もうすごい智慧のある第三者が決めなくちゃいけないんですよ
もし私は言うなら私が正しいと
それでいえ あんたは間違って私は正しいと
それで私はお互いに殺し合いやるんじゃなくて
智慧のある第三者のところに行って調べてくださいと
私はこういう言い分です
それでこの方はこういう言い分です
どちらの言い分は理にかなっているか
というふうに第三者が決めるべきものであって
戦争の場合 そうじゃないでしょうに
私が正しい 相手が間違っている
だから殺してやると それでどんな理屈ですかね
あるの たとえ間違っても
なぜ戦争する必要あるんですかね
それは一つ もう一つは
自分が強い 死ぬわけはないんだと
という気持ち それを全部経典の
いろんなところにあるものを
私は日本語で言ってるんですけどね
自分が強くて死ぬわけじゃないんだと思うんだと
それも非論理的でしょ
人間は強いわけじゃないんです
死なないわけでもないんです
なのに 私にはこれぐらい財産があって
これぐらい武器があって
これぐらい大きな国があって
これぐらいの強い軍隊があるんだから
負けるわけにはいきませんと
負けませんと と思うこと自体
あまりにも非論理的なんですね
それでいてドーンと戦っちゃう
その 2番目の理由は日本にあったでしょうに
日本は負けるはずがないんだと
平気で一般国民に嘘を言って
大量に人を殺しちゃったんですね
だから最初からもうやっぱりこれやばいと
死ぬかもしれない 死ぬんだと
こんな戦いに行ったら思ったら戦争は起こりません
ですから 人間は論理的だったら
私たちは弱いんだと ちょっとしたことで死ぬんだと
だから戦いやめましょうということになるんですよ
でもそう思わないで 屁理屈で思う
いえ すごく強いんだと
大国だと なんだ こんな小さな国々なんかすぐ簡単に潰せるんだと
そういうふうに思っちゃうと戦争が起こるんですよ
例えば北朝鮮の場合は
テレビで見る情報だけなんですけど
いつでも国民に暗示かけてるんですね
偉大なる何々さんが我々の救済主だ
我々をもう救ってくれるんだ
こんなに偉大で もう神様にしてあげてると
金日成とか何とかという化け物を
ただの化け物なんですけど
ものすごい神様に仕立てられて
で もうすべての情報番組も
歌やら賛美歌やら何だかんでも作って
もう幼稚園の子供にまで教えられて
歌わせて踊らさせて いろんなことをして
で 完璧に屁理屈でしょ
全くも科学性も論理性もないでしょうに
それで子供たちそうやってマインドコントロール
されたところで強いと勘違いする
食べ物もないのに 飢えているのに
金日成からすべて頭がおかしくなっていて
テポドンとかなんとかっていうミサイルを作ろうとする
そんなお金あるならば
もう苦しんでいる人々に米ぐらいあげればいいでしょうに
だからこの世の中で理屈
論理はないんですよ 論理があるんだったら
もうそれはすごい素晴らしいことなんです
論理的にはそこら辺で話を終わりますけど
今日もう一つ言葉 忘れちゃったんだ
直感っていうのを どうしますか？
あと十五分ぐらいしゃべりましょうか
まあ直感は十五分ではありませんですけどね
ちょっと私にとってはこのタイトルは
もうあまりにも大胆すぎですよ
ちょっと扱いにくいんです
あの なぜならば 私もすごく気をつけて
気をつけて これでも気をつけて喋ってるんですよ
失礼なことを全く言わないで
ですから本当に論理って何なのかというと
やっぱり遠慮はできなくなっちゃうんです
バンバンと言わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃう
論理だからね 論理っていうのはバンバンと言うことだからね
だから それで直感というものは何なのかって
皆様それ説明だけします
皆様方が思っている直感がありますね
で 仏教ではあの論理と直感
両方認めるんですよ 両方必要ですよ
今 論理のことはもういくらか
わかるでしょうと思いますけどね
いくらかですよ ものすごい
もう今日はたくさん言いたいことがありまして
もう全部忘れちゃった
どのように論理作るか
論理構成をどうしますか？とかね
何が論理で何が論理でないかとかね
もうたくさんあります
で 直感って何なのかと
そこでこれだけ覚えておいてください
一般的に我々が言ってる直感は
あれダメですよ あの直感はやめた方がいいんです
普通の我々 日常生活で使うでしょ
私の直感でわかったんですよとか何とかとかね
あの直感は一番危険
だから自分が思ったことは後でぴったし
合いましたかないかということは問題ではありません
日本語で これは日本語の問題です
普通の日本語で
直感という意味は
その意味で今説明しています
その場合 直感というのはあまり
情報があったわけじゃないんですよ
証拠があったわけでもないんです
ただなんとなく自分の気持ちでそう思ったんです
直感で だから 試験なんかはね
選択でしょう 5つが 1 2
3 4 5ぐらいあってね
1つ選ぶことだから もう勉強する必要ないんですよ
直感で全部もうバツをバツですか
もうバツ印を書いてくればいいんだから
だからそういう それはもういい加減なんですよ
その直感というのは変なんです
ほとんどそれ直感と言わない
仏教は とにかくそれはもう
とっくにご存知だと思いますけど
私は違うことを言いたいんですね
時々それは女の勘ですよとかね
よく言う場合もあるし
で 女にだけじゃなくて
男の人もそうやって直感でアホなことはよくやりますけど
で 競馬とかね やってるでしょうに
一つも当たらないでしょうに
まあどちらも同じなんですけど
あまり理屈使わない
あまり情報を取って対照して調べようとしないで
じゃあこれにしますというふうな感じの心の働きなんですね
今 直感というのは でも本当に仏教で直感というのは直と感なんです
間がないという意味なんです
文字通りの直感なんです
それは 100%合ってるんです
論理の場合は間があるんです
結論まで いわゆる情報があって
この情報の段取りを得て真理に至ると
直感というのは間がなく
もう結論と じゃあそれをちょっとした
例でわかりやすく説明します
この部屋は涼しいんですね
なぜ涼しいですかね この部屋は涼しいでしょうし
なぜ涼しいですか？これはもう簡単に
そんなに厳密に言わなくてもいいんでしょうし
ただ冷房がついてるからなんです
冷房ついてるから涼しいんです
もうわかりやすいことで間違いますかね
それは この部屋に冷房がついてます
だから涼しいですよというのは言うまでもないこと
当たり前のこと それは百パーセント合っている
合っている これは例ですよ
もっと厳しいんですけど
直感というのは そこで冷房はついている
それなのに暑くて汗がタラタラ状態でいると
その時どうします？
この部屋に冷房がついているし
フル回転しているし それでもなかなかもう暑くて汗がタラタラもう
垂らしながらも座っていられない状態
その場合は我々は論理を使うんです
真理を知るために
それで論理を使うんです
あれ なんでしょうね 冷房はついてるんだけど
もしかするとスイッチの入れ間違いではないかと
冷房ではなくて暖房になってるんではないかとかね
暖房になってない冷房の機能です
あるいは空気が詰まってるんではないかと
そうやって論理に行くんですよ
そこで空気も詰まってるわけじゃないと
であるならば なんで暖かいんですかと
それ探してみると あ こういうことだと原因見つかるんですね
何かの原因 例えば窓からずっと直射して
太陽の日光が入ってるんだと
すると あ おそらくこの冷房で
いくら空気を冷やしても
太陽の方がより暑くて暖めているんだと
だからなかなか涼しくならないんだよ
というふうに結論に至る
それは間違ってるんじゃないんですよ
間違ってるんじゃない
正しい結論に至りました
真理を発見しました でも過程があったんですよ
直感の場合は何のことない
あ 涼しいな 冷房ついてるんだから
それで終わり だから理屈は入らないんです
だから直感っていうのは
この論理過程入らないで
瞬時に真理に至る
ですから直感っていうのは楽なんですよ
考えなくてもいいんだから
でも日常生活でいう直感とは違うんです
日常生活で我々普通に言ってる
もうあなたの直感ですねとか
皆さん あんなものは当てにならない
もういい加減で全然当てにならない
全く捨てた方がいい 直感に頼らない方がいい
ろくなものにならない
でも仏教でいう直感というのはそうじゃなくて
パッと100パーセント正しい真理に
結論に答えに至る　その100パーセント正しい答えに
段取りを得て至るんだったら
論理で段取りなしにパッといったならば直感で
だからもうちょっといろんな例で考えましょう
で 私は立っていたんだから疲れたと
で 座る 座ったらあ 楽になったと
あ 座ったんだから楽になった
で このすぐわかること
間違いなくわかること
ですから 瞑想では
ここら辺は訓練させるんですよ
人間が100パーセントの絶対変わらぬ
真理にあってほしいんですよ
推測はもう意味がないんですよ
だから我々の脳の能力をさらに育てなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから 論理過程で
やっと真理見つかったんだと
言ったとしても意味がないんです
なぜ意味がないかというと
はっきり実感がないんですよ
この論理過程で真理に至っても
例えばこの私は我々説法で
全てのものはdukkhaであると
無常であると 実体はないと
徹底的に論理的に説明していくんでしょうに
いくら徹底的に論理的に説明しても
皆様方納得いっても何か欠けているんですよ
実感がないんです だから論理過程で真理に至っても納得はいく
それしかないんだと でも実感がない
だから実感っていうのは直感で出てくるんです
だから直感っていうのは
例えば私は皆様に じゃあ口を開けてください
飴入れますから といって何か口に入れちゃう
入れて飴だと思って舐めてみると
これでまあ嫌な味で ものすごい苦いと
そうすると その味わった人が
ものすごく嫌な顔をするでしょうね
あまりにも苦くて 日本で本当に苦いものはないんですね
例を出したいんだけどね
自分の国だったらもう死ぬほど苦いものはありますよ
なんか日本にありますか
ものすごい苦い何か え？え？そういうものは私は知らないんですけどね
日本の植物関係ではそれほどないと思いますけどね
地球の位置によってね
植物の味が変わりますからね
南の方に行くと はっきりと味が変わっている
区別明確にするようになっちゃいますからね
ある植物があります
あれは薬なんですけど
舐めてちょっとでも試しで遊びで舐めてみたら
1週間苦いというぐらい苦いんですよ
一回その苦みを感じたら
あの香りが来る時でも
もう苦いという気持ちがわかるほど
でも悪いことにものすごく体にいい薬なんです
だからそういう何か病気になったら
否が応なしに飲まなくちゃいけないことにもなりますけど
そういう植物もあります
とにかく飴だと思って
私はそうやって何か苦いものを口に
入れてあげたりする そうすると
本人が前もってこれは飴でしょう
ですから甘いでしょう
だから美味しいでしょうという先入観がいっぱいもある
先入観もいっぱいあるのにも関わらず
口に舐めてみたところで
まあ嫌で苦くて それで私は聞く
美味しいでしょ？どう答えますか？
もう殴られるかもしれませんし
美味しいところではなくてね
それで私はその人に説得させようとする
あなたはそんな苦いと思っても
これは甘いんですよ 美味しいんですよと
だから私の言うことを信じなさいよ
言っても信じないでしょうに
あなたの言うことを信じません
私の口に入ったものはとんでもない味でしたと
それは直感ですよ 直感だから誰が聞いても聞かない
誰にも説得することはできません
いくら先入観があっても
もう直感では全部なくなっちゃうんです
直感というのはそういうことで
すごい強烈で事実なんです
ですから 無常っていうのは直感で
見てくださいということなんです
そうすると お釈迦様は信じる必要ないんです
そういうことだから 瞑想を通して
直感の仕方を育てるんですよ
だから我々ヴィパッサナー瞑想で痛みを感じたら
余計なことを考えないで
痛みとちゃんと確認してみなさい
なんで痛いだろうと思ったら
もう追い出すんです
追い出すことはしませんけど
気持ちとしては出ていけという気持ちなんです
あなたは無理やと 頭は育てません
例えば座って座禅組んで
ヴィパッサナー瞑想していると
足が痛くて痛くてたまらなかったんだと
だから痛みと確認してくださいと
いや まあ確認はしたんだけど
なかなか消えませんねとかね
それだったらお釈迦様は思っている
智慧が出てこないんですよ
なぜかというと もう固定概念で消えるだろうと希望があって
で 理屈が使ったりして
で ヴィパッサナーで何を育てるかで
この直感を育てるんですよ
で 痛みは痛みで確認する
痺れだと思ったら これを痺れとして確認する
なんで痺れるんだろうかと思ったら理屈でしょ
そうすると痺れる原因はいちいち
過程を経て調べなくちゃあかんでしょうね
それは揺らぎ それは揺れる智慧なんです
揺らぎない智慧ではないんです
だから痛みで止まったら
それは揺らぎない経験なんですね
そうやって この論理的な
いわゆる過程を経てから得る智慧と過程を踏まないで直接
得る智慧という2つ分けてあって
仏教は悟りとして認めるのはこの直感の智慧なんです
それはもう揺らぎません
誰が何と言おうとも もうどうにもならない
それ体験しちゃったらもう
もう事実を自分で発見したんだから
だからそこら辺まで仏教の心の働き
すごい厳密にしているんです
無常だろうというのはダメですよ
せっかくお釈迦様がおっしゃってるんだから
やっぱり無常でしょう
何の役にも立たない
せっかく偉大なるお釈迦様がおっしゃってるんだからね
まあ やっぱり人生は苦しみでしょうね
それは何の意味もないんです
そういうのは論理的に仮定であって
直感というのは自分で舐めてみたことと同じなんです
で それで論理構成悪いと
思う これ説明するちょっとした物語が
その仏教的じゃない その物語で話を終了します
一回も同じことを言ったんです
ある若者が大量にヨーグルトを作って
たくさん 昔話で ヨーグルトっていうのは簡単に作れますからね
牛乳をちょっと温めて
固める何かヨーグルトの種ですけど
前のヨーグルトちょっと入れちゃったら
固まりますからね ヨーグルトを作って
これ売りに行くんです
おいしいヨーグルトですよ
おいしいヨーグルトいかがでしょうか？と売りに行ったら
そこら辺で生まれつき目が見えない人がいたんですね
いたら その人はヨーグルトを見たことがないんです
ここで聞くんですよ 君
このヨーグルトって何でしょうかと
これはすごい もう美味しいものですよ
そしたら まあというならば買いたいんだけど
買う前に調べたいんですけど
どのようなものですか？と
言ったら そう言われても
これはすごい真っ白いんだ
ヨーグルト 真っ白いと言っても
わかりませんから真っ白いってどんなものかと
真っ白いっていうのは
鶴のように 鶴のような色ですよと
鶴のような色ですって言っても目が見えないでしょうに
わからないんですよ あんた鶴知らないんですか？と
鶴っていうのはこんな形の鳥ですよと
手で鶴の形をして見せたんです
そこで目が見えない人はこうやって触ってみて
あ なるほど こんな形のものか
じゃあヨーグルト要りませんと
じゃあ決めました ヨーグルト要りませんと
こんなものは要りませんから
ですから 仮定をして考えちゃうと
そういう問題になるんです
だから目が見えない人でも
白いとかね 認識次元に関係ないものを言わないで
これは食べたら美味しいですよと
舐めたら美味しいですと言ったら
その目が見えない人はもう幸せになるはずでしたけどね
ですから 人間にわからないものをね
言ったとしても無意味なんですよ
だから目が見えない人にヨーグルトは
鶴のようなものだと言ったところで
とんでもない結論に至ってしまったんだから
ですから この我々生きている世界で
まあ宗教であろうが何であろうか
もう人間にもわけもわからない
科学では説明できないものはいっぱい
ありますよと言っていい加減なことを言う
こんな幽霊現象は それは科学では説明できませんと
でも私も大槻教授の立場で
いい加減なことを言うなよと
科学で説明できない 人間の知識範囲で
説明できないんだったら放っておけと
そんなものは 言ってることは嘘でしょうと
科学でも説明できないものは
どうやって科学知識 能力何もない馬鹿者に説明できるんですかね
たとえ 例えば写真撮ったところで
そこで幽霊が写ってあったんだと
それは科学者に説明できないんだと
だったら どこかにいるね
くだらない人に説明できますかね？
やっぱりこれは幽霊です
これはもう亡くなったおばあさんがあなたの前に
恨んでるんですよと平気で言うでしょうね
あんた気をつけなさいよと
事故を起こすかもしれませんと
だからそうやって人間を騙されるんですよ
簡単に だからもう世の中の科学を
信じた方がより簡単でしょうしね
科学者に聞いてみれば
この写真はどんな写真かと
それでもう光の光学とかいろいろあるでしょうね
いろいろ見て まあまあ
こういうことではないかと説明してくれると思いますし
だから科学で説明できないものだからと事実というわけでもないし
何でも科学で説明できるわけでもないんでしょうし
とにかく人間の認識に入らないものを言っても
無意味ですということだけ言いたいんですけど
とにかくそういうことで
論理は大変大事なもので
真理を理解するために
それからはっきりした変わらぬ真理を知るために
直感というものは使う必要があります
ですからちょっと左と右いじっただけではできません
ちゃんともう一つの脳の機能を
育てなくちゃいけないんですから
それは瞑想を通して教えているので
どうもありがとうございます